[Musique]
dans cette séquence on va aborder la
conduite à tenir à avoir face à une
personne qui est inconsciente mais qui
respire là j'arrive près de du jeune qui
est sur le sol je regarde effectivement
si il y a un saignement important non et
là je vais commencer avec vérifier si il
parle tu m'entends sers-moi la main des
yeux et là pas de réaction la victime
est donc inconsciente il va falloir
qu'on bascule la tête en arrière pour
libérer les voies aériennes en fait la
scolarité est inconsciente elle est bien
plus molle que lorsqu'elle dort
tellement molle qu'effectivement la
langue a tendance à descendre le
problématique c'est qu'effectivement ce
qui est dans son ventre et très liquide
ça peut sortir il peut se mettre à vomir
et là si il vomit les sécrétions
gastriques peuvent descendre dans la
gorge et comme il respire ça va dans les
poumons il va mourir noyer dans son vomi
donc il faut le mettre sur le côté pour
cela on commence retirer les lunettes
pour préserver le visage rassemblez les
jambes le bras qui est de notre côté on
va le mettre faire deux angles droits
vers le haut pour libérer l'articulation
faire l'affaire circulation sanguine se
fasse bien prendre la main opposée la
mettre contre son oreille ça va garder
la tête les voies aériennes libérées le
temps du retournement soulevez le genou
extérieur pour faire un bras de levier
et donc sans effort même si la victime
est plus lourde que nous en appuyant sur
le genou ça tourne tout seul ma main
bloquée je la retire en retenant son
coude j'enlève le masque je j'ouvre sa
bouche pour que les sécrétions
gastriques sanguines et salivaires
puissant l'aller et là je vais
stabiliser le bassin en mettant l'axe
genou hanche perpendiculaire au ventre
on va couvrir la victime avec un pull
une couverture de survie pour la
préserver donc des intempéries et
préserver sa température corporelle
on prévient les secours pour dire que la
victime est en position latérale de
sécurité et on va surveiller il faut
vérifier qu'il continue à ventiler
t'inquiète pas les secours vont arriver
les victimes qui entendent tout jusqu'à
l'hôpital donc on continue à leur parler
je vais mettre la main sur votre ventre
et là il faut qu'on puisse sentir les
mouvements du ventre pour s'assurer que
la victime respire et donc assurer la
surveillance jusqu'à l'arrivée des
secours